- Welcome back.
Before we say goodbye, we
like to play a quick round of-
- Drewth or Dare.
(audience cheering)
All right, Malcolm Minor.
Hi.
- Hi, how you doing?
- Fantastic, thank you.
Is it a Drewth or a dare?
- It's a dare.
- Okay, what is it?
- So since it's pasta week,
I dare you, both of you,
to have a pasta eating contest.
No hands so you have
to dive in face first.
- So do what I do at home?
This is why I don't
want sexy music playing.
- Oh, okay.
Okay. I'm all.
Are you ready to get messy?
- Well, I'm excited,
because I don't know what
is gonna happen here.
And I don't, I mean, in all seriousness
I haven't done this.
- Oh, okay.
- Contrary to what you might think.
- So no hands
and we're just gonna,
just get in it, Malcolm?
- Just go in.
- [Ross] Okay. Okay.
- Try to protect the wardrobe.
This is a very well fitted lab coat.
This is a contest, Ross,
at the end of the day.
So you would never pus around with me
and I'm not doing it with you either,
so it's game time.
- All right, Barrymore. Let's do this.
(audience cheering)
Oh my God.
- You're not my bestie right now.
- Okay. Game face on and
then face in the pasta.
Oh gosh, she's in.
Oh my God.
(audience cheering)
I got sauce in my nose.
(audience laughing and cheering)
Hey, Drew, you got a little, right there.
- Well, Malcolm, is this
what you had in mind?
- Pretty much. (laughing)
(hosts laughing)
- Well, I have to say Malcolm.
I have never had tomato sauce up my nose.
- [Ross] Nope. Nope.
Thank you Malcolm.
(audience applauds)
Oh my gosh. Up my nose.
- I mean literally, totally up my nose.
Well, thank you guys.
And I mean this with all
of my heart and sincerity.
I'm so glad that you guys
came to visit us today.
Thank you so much.
Really and truly.
(theme music playing)